ce matin là au lycée descartes les
étudiants de première année de classe
préparatoire scientifique suivre un
cours de physique mécanique sur les
solides rotations autour d'un axe fixe
cette classe préparatoire fête cette
année ses 10 ans intégrer directement
après le bac elle permet aux étudiants
de se former durant deux ans et obtenir
ensuite les concours d'entrée aux écoles
d'ingénieurs
j'aime bien le rythme et où l'on doit
être toujours boosté par les profs de
toujours aller au delà du mythe a besoin
de leur forme et ont versé les études
particularité de la classe prépa pcs et
du lycée descartes son partenariat
direct avec l'université en 2008 elle
était la première à fonctionner ainsi
cette décennie marque son efficacité une
journée par semaine nos étudiants vont à
l'ufr des sciences à versailles est en
fait ils bénéficient d du matériel des
techniciens de l'université qui vont les
aider donc pour les tp l'avantagé qu'on
a toujours du matériel en très grand
nombre d'exemplaires alors que l'indicé
standard va avoir du pour du matériel un
petit peu cher un ou deux exemplaires
les étudiants viennent principalement du
bassin saint quentinois
nul besoin de se rendre dans les plus
prestigieux lycée parisien pour viser
les meilleures écoles d'autant plus que
peu nombreux par promotion il bénéficie
d'un vrai suivi personnalisé de la part
de leurs professeurs le matin juin vélo
par exemple et donc ça ça un facteur à
prendre en compte je pense pour
l'épanouissement
vraiment on connaît nos élèves
nos étudiants parker qu'on a l'habitude
de dire une classe un professeur donc
cette année vous avez vu les 25 et qui
était là et sur le jeu n'est que 25
élèves devant moi toute l'année dans dix
ans la classe préparatoire du lycée
descartes a pu faire rentrer ses
étudiants dans les plus grandes écoles
d'ingénieurs seuls 15 % d'entre eux se
sont orientés